hey  i'm fairly new to the cloud world and i  want to get a certification so i can  prove to my employer that i'm ready  which one should i get that's a great  idea  you should check out the google cloud  associate cloud engineer certification  you are expected to know how to use the  platform set up plan implement configure  and secure a cloud solution is there a  prerequisite not really but it is  recommended that you have six months of  hands-on experience with google cloud  since this is a practitioner exam the  more real-world experience you have the  better i'm also working on a side  project building and deploying an app on  google cloud that is honestly the best  way to get prepared for a test but if  you need more resources check out the  learning path here rate i'm going to go  prepare  good luck and make sure to start with  the exam guide review